if it's been a while since you've seen
the first two Jumanji films or you've
avoided the Sinister game until now
we've got you covered we've gathered
everything you need to know before you
see Jumanji the next level including
past events new characters and more
gather up your gear because we're
heading back into the jungle
the original Jumanji film is based on
the 1981 picture book of the same name
by Chris Van osburgh in which a pair of
siblings named Judy and Peter Shepherd
come across the titular board game in
the park in the films the characters
come upon the game in much the same way
with all of them happening upon it
seemingly by accident
although the film's imply that the game
has a degree of sentient Stu it and can
manipulate circumstances so it can be
found and played after finding a board
game called Jumanji at a construction
site in 1969 Alan Parrish begins playing
with his friend Sarah Whittle however
they've barely begun to play when Alan
is sucked into the game with a message
that he must wait in the jungle until
someone rolls a 5 or 8 but instead of
taking her turn the terrified Sarah
flees from the house and the game is
placed in the Attic later in 1995
orphans Judy and Peter Shepard move into
Alan Parrish his old house with their
aunts and discover the game in the Attic
they begin to play and Peter's role
releases Alan from the game where's my
mom and dad now an adult Alan has been
living in the jungle for the past 26
years and he uses the skills he's
acquired there to help the children fend
off the animals and natural disasters
that emerge from the game however since
the game from 1969 was never finished
they have to find the adult Sarah and
convince her to take her turn so that
they can complete the game and return
everything to normal after taking turns
that results in the game unleashing
increasingly catastrophic levels of
mayhem and destruction
Alan finally finishes the game and says
Junichi everything is returned to its
pre game States including Alan going
back to 1969 where he grows up to marry
Sarah and prevent the accident that
killed Judy and Peter's parents while
the game of Jumanji is undeniably tricky
and deliberately misleading it is at its
heart still a game the rules written on
the board game States you roll the dice
to move your token doubles get another
turn and the first player to reach the
end wins with each turn the game creates
a new obstacle for the players to face
making it progressively
more difficult to finish the game
through playing the characters learned
that knowing can forfeit leave the game
or skip a turn and there are
consequences for attempting to cheat in
order to end the game sooner after
completing their final turn the winning
player must say the word Jumanji out
loud in order to end the game over the
course of the films however the board
game shifts its form to become a video
game so naturally some of the rules had
to change but the basics have stayed the
same die specific stipulations such as
the doubles rule no longer apply but
players still have to complete the game
once it started can't forfeit or quit
and have to say Jumanji out loud in
order to finish it in bolt Jumanji and
Jumanji welcome to the jungle a player
gets trapped inside the game for decades
due to no one being able to beat it and
Alan Parrish his case his problem was
that Sarah stopped playing and therefore
didn't roll the five or eight that was
needed in order to bring him out even
when Judy and Peter thought they were
starting a new game they were really
just continuing Alan and Sarah's game
from 26 years earlier then and welcome
to the jungle Alex gets caught inside
the game for 21 years after his father
finds it on the beach in 1996 where it
washed up after Alan and Sarah threw it
in the river in 1969 while the original
version of Jumanji was a board game and
thus required at least two players once
it shifted into a quest based video game
version it became possible to play as a
solo player however while Alex
technically could have completed the
game by himself
he wound up stuck when he came up
against an obstacle he couldn't get past
on his own like alan alex required other
players to join in later to finish the
game and return them all to their pre
game state if you're unlucky enough to
get caught inside Jumanji and there's no
one around to take the next turn or you
can't complete the game on your own
you'll simply be stuck playing forever
unlike Sarah and Allen or Judy and Peter
the for teenagers who go on to play the
game and welcome to the jungle aren't
friends siblings are really much of
anything
Spencer Bethany Martha and fridge are
all students at Brantford High School
and that's about whether similarities
and Spencer and fridge were best friends
as kids but now their relationship
consists entirely of Spencer doing
fridges homework form and while Spencer
admires Martha from afar they don't
really talk meanwhile Bethany is off in
her own self-absorbed world and she
doesn't seem to notice any of the others
the four sentenced to serve detention
together in the school storage room on a
Saturday removing staples from magazines
so they can be recycled rather than
engaged in their tedious
they decide to play a video game fridge
discovers among the shelves and soon
they find themselves trapped inside
Jumanji after a harrowing adventure
inside the game including a number of
near-death and actual death experiences
before learned to lean on and appreciate
one another and they emerge from the
game as good friends with a new outlook
on life
Bethany learns to be brave and selfless
Martha finds confidence fridge learns
humility and Spencer learns to lead and
conquer his fears
in addition fridge and Spencer rekindle
their friendship and Spencer and Martha
embark on a romantic relationship while
the main characters of Jumanji welcome
to the jungle are Spencer Martha fridge
and Bethany the people we spend most of
the time watching in the film aren't
technically people at all instead
they're video game avatars avatars are
characters that exist within the game
and are controlled by outside players
and and welcome to the jungle each
character spends most of the film
occupying the body of their chosen
avatar I look like a living garden gnome
where is my phone Oh different people's
bodies each avatar has its own strengths
and weaknesses which remain with the
avatar in a matter which player is
controlling it Rubi roundhouse Martha's
avatar is proficient in karate Tai Chi
Aikido and dance fighting over
weaknesses venom Bethenny's Avatar is
professor Oberon and his strengths are
cartography archaeology and paleontology
and his weaknesses endurance meanwhile
Mouse the avatar fridge boasts an
impressive knowledge of zoology and an
equally impressive variety of weapons
while these weaknesses are cake speed
and strength
Spencer's avatar is smolder brave stone
and a strengths are speed throwing
boomerangs climbing being fearless and
his smoldering intensity he has zero
weaknesses see plain McDonough the
avatar of Alex tells us that his
strengths are piloting and margaritas
and that one of his weaknesses is
mosquitoes but he doesn't mention what
the others may be although the board
game version of Jumanji had several
rules specific to rolling dice the video
game version adapts the mechanics of its
gameplay to fit its new format now
instead of taking turns the players work
together to complete levels each with
its own goals and challenges the levels
get increasingly more difficult as
players progress through the game and
all build toward an ultimate end goal
additionally each character starts the
game with three lives although it's
possible for one player to transfer one
of their extra lives to another player
under dire circumstances if a player
dies
assuming that they have an additional
life they'll respawn along with any
objects they were holding when they died
appearing in the sky over the game and
landing and approximately the same spot
Jumanji also includes several NPCs or
non player characters that interact with
the characters avatars and either guide
them on their way or attempt to work
against them
the main NPCs and welcome to the jungle
are Nigel who serves as a guide for the
characters and Van Pelt's who's the
game's antagonist Van Pelt also existed
in the board game version of Jumanji as
a big-game hunter
determined to keep Alan and the other
players from completing the game and
welcome to the jungle Van Pelt is given
a more thorough backstory and a similar
goal to the player characters but his
role as the game's resident bad guy
appears to be a Jumanji constant so what
exactly happens in Jumanji welcome to
the jungle well after getting trapped
inside Jumanji and after a period of
initial confusion and denial Spencer
Martha fridge and Bethany have to work
together to deliver a magical jewel
called the Jaguars eye to a giant Jaguar
statue before the sinister Russell Van
Pelt can get his hands on it possessed
by the power of the jewel Van Pelt is
able to control Jumanji XANA muls which
works against the players as they
attempt to complete their task the group
is given clues meant to inform their
quest which leads them to Alex's avatar
who started the game in 1996 but had
gotten stuck when he found himself down
to his last life on a challenge he
didn't know how to complete drawing on
their avatars collective strengths the
group is finally able to beat the level
that had thwarted Alex for so long
though Alex loses his life in the
process and Bethany has to transfer one
of her extra lives to him through CPR
the five players reach the statue to
return the jewel and call out Jumanji
ending the game shaking hands with each
of them Nigel returns them to their
lives at the moment before they entered
the game before Brantford high-teens
walked to the previously rundown Greek
home where they encounter and now grown
up alex who tells them he'd emerged from
the game in 1996 and had lived a good
life naming his oldest daughter Bethany
later the 14s destroy the game almost
every major player from Jumanji welcome
to the jungle is coming back for Jumanji
in the next level although we'll get to
see several of them in a brand new light
in fact the entire main cast including
Rhys Darby's Nigel and Colin Hanks as
Alex will be returning for the next
installment in the series the only
significant character from welcome to
the jungle who had
have been confirmed for the sequel is
Bobby Cannavale II who played the
villainous Van Pelt
however while most of the faces in the
next level will be familiar some of the
actors will be portraying totally
different characters due to Jumanji use
of avatars only Karen Gillan will be
portraying the same character as she did
and welcome to the jungle fridge who
played as Kevin Hart's mouth spin bar
the first time around will now be
controlling Jack Black Shelli Oberon
while Dwayne the rock Johnson and Hart
will be portraying the avatars of two
brand-new characters
Spencer's grandfather Eddie and Eddie's
friend Milo we've yet to learn which
avatars Bethany in Spencer wind up
controlling or if Alex reenters the game
at all but one thing's for sure this
game will be very different from the
last one we did we in hell joining the
cast for Jumanji the next level our
comedic acting legends Danny DeVito and
Danny Glover playing Spencer's
grandfather
Eddie Gilpin and his friend Michael
Walker respectively if the next level
follows the same format as welcome to
the jungle we don't expect to see debido
or Glover on screen for very long but it
looks like the characters will still
have a significant presence in the movie
after they accidentally enter the game
and wind up controlling the avatars
portrayed by Dwayne Johnson and Kevin
parked also coming to board for the next
Jumanji outing or once upon a time's
Daniel Ramirez and crazy rich Asians and
the farewell star aquafina both in
undisclosed roles while Ramirez doesn't
appear in the trailer of all the brief
glimpses we get of Aquafina suggests
you'll be playing a character within the
game although whether she'll be another
avatar or a new npc as anyone's guess
whoever she is sources have told The
Hollywood Reporter that acqua penis role
is more significant than just a cameo
leading us to guess that she's likely
either an avatar for one of the players
possibly Spencer Bethany or even Alex or
she's the game's new villain check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you
[Music]